comme le dit mademoiselle moulin il
savait tout georges bidault prendra sa
succession
mais voici la victoire de ce silence
atrocement payer le destin bascule chef
de la résistance martyrisée dans des
caves hideuse regarde de tes yeux
disparu
toutes ces femmes noires qui veillent
nos compagnons elle porte le deuil de la
france est le tien regard de glisser
sous les chênes vins du quercy avec un
drapeau fait de mousseline nous et les
maquis que la gestapo ne trouvera jamais
parce qu'elle ne croit qu'aux grands
arbres regarde le prisonnier qui entre
dans une villa luxueuse et se demande
pourquoi on lui donne une salle de bain
il n'a pas encore entendu parler de r&d
noir comme bloquer rentra aux invalides
avec son cortège d'exaltation dans le
soleil d'afrique entre ici jean moulin
avec ton terrible cortège avec ceux qui
sont morts dans les caves sans avoir
parlé comme toi et même ce qui est peut
être plus atroces en ayant parlé avec
tous les rayés et tout l'étendu des
camps de concentration avec le dernier
corps trébuchon des affreuses fils de
nuit et brouillard
enfin tombé sous les cross avec les 8000
françaises qui ne sont pas revenus des
bagnes avec la dernière femme morte à
ravensbrück pour avoir donner asile à
l'un des nôtres on sera avec le peuple
n'est de lompret disparu avec elle
nos frais
rentrer de laly commémorons
l'anniversaire de la libération de paris
je disais écoute ce soir jeunesse de mon
pays
les cloches d'anniversaire qui sonneront
comme celle d'il ya 14 ans puisse tout
cette fois les entendre elles vont
sonner pour toi l'hommage d'aujourd'hui
l'appel que le champ qui va s'élever
maintenant ce chant des partisans que
j'ai entendu murmurer comme un chant de
complicité puis l'allemagne et dans le
brouillard des projets des voix d'alsace
mais les hauts cris perdu des moutons
des tabors fois les bazookas scorait
avançait à la rencontre des chars de
rundstedt lancé nouveau contre
strasbourg et coûte aujourd'hui jeunesse
de france ce qui fut pour nous le show
du malheur c'est la marche funèbre
descendre que voici
à côté de celle de carnot avec les
soldats de l'an ii de celle de victor
hugo avec les misérables de celle de
jaurès veillé par l'injustice qu'elle
repose avec leur lot cortège dont
bretez figurer aujourd'hui jeunesse lis
tu pensé à cet homme comme tu aurait
approché des mains de sa pauvre face
informe du dernier jour de salaire qui
n'avait pas parlé
ce jour là elle était le visage de la
france